ça ne rame pas parce que je me sens 100%
martiniquaise nous appelons mardi non
j'ai pas né en martinique parce que papa
est rentré à la mort de son père dans
l'armée de moi je suis à toulouse j'ai
vécu un peu en afrique
voilà mais je reviens profs et parents à
la martinique
j'habite actuellement le diamant alors
vous êtes attaché par trois je dirais
trois personnes à la marque en
génération trois générations en
générations donc pour moi c'est
important même si la mère et
métropolitaine et du limousin
mais j'ai vécu avec le ti punch les
acras mourut le colombo de cabri
moi même je sais très bien cuisiner donc
pour moi la martinique que je fais
partie aussi je dirais de mon chemin
pour moi c'est une obligation et voilà
et j'ai donc plaisir emmené incident et
des élus quand on vient ici je voyais
aujourd'hui nous sommes une quinzaine
elles viennent avec leurs époux leurs
épouses et surtout leur faire découvrir
mais on ne vit pas l'hôtel on vit chez
l'habitant et on mange antilles et moi
ce qui est important c'est de faire
connaître la marque unique autrement que
par les médias je pense que quand on est
en métropole on voit certaines choses on
parle de la martinique que ce par
rapport aux autres aux ouragans
aussi il ya eu quelque chose
d'exceptionnel mais il ya plein de
choses
c'est toute la culture et je pense que
c'est important de le faire pour dire
connaître aux métropolitains la culture
notre culture voilà il ya aussi toute
l'essence
regardez quand on est dans ce jardin
aujourd'hui au niveau des armes au
niveau des fleurs il ya tellement de
connaissances à voir la musique aussi
qui est importante
les mais ce que l'on mange voilà
découvrir c'est un fait que quand je les
fais venir ici nous n'allons pas à
l'hôtel
c'est une première règle voilà la
deuxième règle et doivent payer leur
voyage
ce n'est pas la commune qui paye le
voyage c'est nous qui payons notre
voyage ensuite on va chez l'habitant et
on passe par un thé restaurateurs que
nous livre tout le soir on joue tous
ensemble mais on mange autour d'un repas
antillais pas d'un repas metropolit et
on a largement le temps de le faire et
ce qui est important c'est que nous
prenons
en deux minibus de neuf places 1 que mon
époux conduit est un que je conduis moi
même comme ça et peut voir le paysage
pour leur expliquer en même temps ce
qu'une voix